also in carolina news as new coach matt
rule continues to put together his first
staff joe brady a name you heard a lot
about on monday night the
assistant coach at lsu who had been with
the saints before that he will be the
offensive coordinator of the carolina
panthers 30 years old working with matt
rule putting together passing game
running game everything in the offense
for the carolina panthers chris your
reaction when you saw that this 30 year
old passing game coordinator from the
national champion is heading to the nfl
to work with matt well i mean i i mean
this is a shocking story i'm not going
to say i was shocked yesterday because
there was a lot of rumors that joe brady
was going to end up in the nfl for
somebody as an offensive coordinator it
makes sense that he goes to matt rule i
mean this is an unbelievable resume i
mean the fact that he was a linebacker
coach a graduate assistant at penn state
for two years and then just an offensive
assistant with the saints for two years
and then comes to the you know lsu
national championship football team and
their offense just skyrockets and
explodes to any you know to something
we've never seen a school like lsu have
before
i get it you know and matt rule
obviously liked what he saw you know
breaking down film or whatever it may be
he's a young new energetic offensive
mind is he ready for the nfl we'll see i
mean those are these are these are
highers where i go i gotta see it to
believe it a little bit now do i like
his offense mike i do from everything
i've seen have i studied it yet no i
will when we get into the draft and i
really get to study joe burrow and
things like that but i will say this
just at my first glance i like this
offense better than lincoln riley or
cliff kingsbury or those offenses who
have you know either in the nfl are
being talked about so uh you know
there's things to like here certainly
we'll just see if he's ready for the job
and of course the speculation that
emerged immediately after the news of
joe brady coming to the panthers the
panthers will now try to get up to the
number one spot in the draft so joe
burrow can come from lsu to the carolina
panthers i don't know that that's the
answer for the panthers but i'll tell
you what chris i already had a sense
that cam newton isn't going to be back
next year
last week from owner right well between
that and luke lee gone right i think
from i think and and this is the thing
that doesn't get discussed enough i
don't think cam is going to want to be
there i think cam is going to feel like
it's time for him to move on and i think
with luke keekley leaving the cam newton
of the defense who arrived one year
after cam did right keegley was the top
10 pick in 2012 cam number one overall
in 2011. i just think that that that
will be viewed as cam newton as just
another indication that it's time to
move on to something else and why stay
here when everything is changing uh i
can go somewhere else if everything's
gonna change i may as well change
location maybe a team that wants to pay
me more money maybe a team in la like
the chargers i've said from the moment
it looked like cam newton may not be
back with the panthers that the charges
make the most sense and i just think
yesterday's events from joe brady to
luke keakley it makes me feel even more
strongly that cam newton won't be back
yeah i don't disagree with you i think
it looks like it's going in that
direction yeah is he going to want to be
a part of matt rule a new head coach a
new offensive mind all those things plus
hey the the theory of joe burrow they
want to get him okay well i mean as it
looks right now you're gonna have to
trade up to number one that's all fine
and dandy i don't know maybe if you
trade cam newton and acquire some assets
maybe you can work a way to get up there
i don't know about that but i'm with you
with all the the signs and things we've
seen here as of late uh i'd be
interested too where cam newton's head's
at does he want to deal with a new
regime a new staff having to learn
probably a completely new language as
far as the offense is concerned uh
it'll be interesting to see what
approach he wants to take here and
really what approach matt rule wants to
take as well
yeah and and look it's got to be a
two-way street when it's quarterback you
have to want to be there and when david
tepper the owner of the team was asked
about it last week about cam newton he
got into this notion of buy-in you've
got to be all in especially the
quarterback they want the quarterback to
be a quasi manager and if he's not all
in if he's not committed to showing up
early staying late being that that
leader for the other players in the
locker room it's just not i'm going to
work what what one yeah and you're right
and one last thing about i mean carolina
here they're they're really i mean you
talk about having some guts and what
they're doing you know matt rule you
know head coach for two different
college programs giving them that kind
of contract seven years sixty something
million dollars you know now here's a
joe brady you know one year calling
plays and in a mate you know in major
football yeah it was really good let's
take into account it was the number one
pick at you know a quarterback uh
probably two top 20 picks at wide
receiver with that number one and number
two i saw the other night i mean they're
they're phenomenal there's a ton of
talent there but what he did the results
they do you know they speak for
themselves that was an incredible year
in the sec
at that plus hey i look at things like
the sec has got a lot of good defenses a
lot of nfl defensive minds are in the
sec and a guy like nick saban had a
whole lot of problems stopping that lsu
offense so i think there's answers here
it's interesting i'm very interested to
see how it all works out because we
haven't really seen a formula like this
i feel like in a while out of nfl team
at least to this extreme
not not this kind of turn it all on its
head right since kelly right that's
right you're right because of kelly
and and because of how it went for chip
kelly in philadelphia and then for one
year in san francisco i think it's one
of the reasons why teams may have shied
away from going the college coach route
but you're right matt rolin joe brady in
who knows who else is coming in but out
in carolina i mean think about it this
is this is the decade for the panthers
the decade ends and the guys who have
been the foundation for the decade are
leaving ron rivera gone luke keegley
gone cam newton may be gone and we'll
see where the panthers go from here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports